well today we're gonna get an
opportunity to look at how we smell well
let me say that again not how we smell
but how we are able to smell and the
person who's going to guide us is dr.
Charles Greer and we're very privileged
to have them because he's a professor of
of neuroscience in addition he's also a
harley-davidson man and today he'll be
talking about what's cleverly titled
sense and sensibilities molecular
mechanisms of olfaction so please let's
welcome him to the podium thank you for
the introduction can you all hear me
okay
it's all right ok so first it's a
pleasure to be here with you today
second I'm happy to entertain questions
at any point so if we're moving along
and there's an issue that comes up that
you'd like to explore in more detail I'm
happy to do that so what am i I'm a
neuroscientist I'm interested in
studying how the brain is organized and
by understanding how its organized
hopefully understanding a little bit
better how it works the brain as a whole
is big and complex and it's got millions
of parts to it so it's hard to study the
brain in its entirety at any given point
so what many of us do many of us working
in the field of the neuroscientists do
instead is we pick out a small part of
the brain in my case the olfactory
system and we decide to study that in
detail we look for the principles that
govern the way that structure functions
how it interacts with other parts of the
brain and then as we understand that
more fully we try to take the lessons
that we've learned in extrapolate and
then look at another part of the brain
so I might begin with the visual system
and take begin with the olfactory system
take what I learned from the olfactory
system and then look at the visual
system and say well how do the
principles that underlie structure and
function in smell how do they apply to
the way visual information is processed
it's like building a house I'm going to
start with one room and then I'm gonna
move on to the next room so that's one
of the reasons that we study the
olfactory system the other reason for
studying the olfactory system is it
plays an important role in our daily
lights you don't recognize it so much I
will talk in more detail about some of
the behavior
that are mediated by the olfactory
system as we go on but suffice it to say
that your ability to appreciate food
your interactions with your friends and
your family and and the pets that may be
part of your lives are all mediated or
strongly influenced by the olfactory
system so there are not many
well-defined diseases that are
associated with the olfactory system
anosmia in general defines a complete
loss of the sense of smell can be either
complete or partial imagine if you will
the inability to smell pizza this
happens to some people they can't smell
pizza anymore
got out dreadful pizza is my favorite
food in the world not being able to
smell it would be terrible other people
have a complete loss of smell this
happens particularly in the age and if
you talk to your grandparents or your
great-grandparents they may tell you
that their sense of smell is not as good
as it used to be we don't understand
fully the mechanisms that may be
responsible for that yet
but we do recognize it happens perros
Mia our changes in the way the olfactory
system functions this is particularly
evident in in women as they become
pregnant will often find odors that
previously had been appealing to them
the smell of ice cream or a particular
perfume or particular kind of food but
as the pregnancy proceeds the smell now
becomes extremely offensive this is a
pair odds be a change in sensitivity or
a change in the in the individuals
response or or or or percept they're
there their recognition of the odor
other than that I think probably one of
the better known diseases is Rhino alexa
mania
though many of you may recognize this
it's characterized by the insertion of a
single digit into the nose with a
vigorous movement of the finger after
insertion so if any of your teachers
give you a problem in class just say
it's not my fault
I've got Rhino til XO me Nia so let's
talk in a little more detail about the
olfactory system first it's a chemical
detector your auditory system detects
changes in pressure that we call sound
your visual system detects changes in
light or differences in light levels
that lead to vision somatosensory we
feel pressure and pricks and so on and
so forth on our digits and elsewhere on
our body the olfactory system is
specialised as a chemical detector
molecules that are floating around in
the environment the molecular identity
of an odor a pizza versus a pork roast
versus a corn of cob of corn and so on
and so forth occurs in a combinatorial
way no I mean by that when you smell
coffee in the morning if you smelled the
coffee that was in the pot out here it's
not just one smell it's many many many
different smells that have come together
that result in which you recognize as
the smell of coffee and in the case of
coffee we know that it's more than a
hundred different molecules that result
in what we call a coffee smell so it's a
combinatorial code you combine all these
different molecules and that combination
then results in this smell it's like a
pizza you get a combination pizza with
lots of stuff on it pepperoni sausage
peppers and so on and so forth that has
one kind of smell if you get just a
cheese pizza with a little bit of tomato
sauce that has a different kind of smell
so as we combine the things together in
a combinatorial code we have the
identity of the odor that we're looking
at the molecular specificity or that
odor code begins with the expression of
a receptor in the membranes of the
sensory neurons that are found inside
our noses and we're going to take a look
at those those in a little more detail
in a few minutes
each sensory neuron in the nose and
there are millions of them expressed as
only one kind of receptor so there's not
a sensory neuron in the
knows for the the combination pizza and
there's not a sensory neuron in the nose
for coffee rather their individual
individual receptors that look at your
small components that will be part of
the combinatorial code the axons from
the nose go into the brain where they
make synapses in central areas of the
brain and then continue on up and we'll
look at what those central areas look
like one of the unique features of the
olfactory system which differentiates it
from almost any other sensory system in
the human is that it has the capacity to
regenerate right now today if you
sustained an injury to your spinal cord
and your legs are paralyzed their
ability to walk in the future is
severely limited you may not be able to
walk at all because the nerves in your
spinal cord are unable to regenerate
that's not true of the olfactory system
the olfactory system regenerates and
reorganizes itself on a daily basis it
begins when we're very young and it
continues through the remainder of our
life and in fact that's another reason
to study the olfactory system is a model
we can look at the principles that
enable the olfactory system to
regenerate on a regular basis take those
principles and apply them to the spinal
cord and ask if we can improve
regeneration by taking features of the
olfactory system and putting them in the
spinal cord and we're not going to talk
about it today but in fact it does
happen we can take components of the
olfactory system put them into the
injured spinal cord and increase the
probability of regeneration occurring so
lots and lots of reasons to study the
olfactory system not the least of which
as I've already mentioned olfaction
affects behavior and we'll come back to
that repeatedly so what is the olfactory
system look like this is a cross-section
of the head see the nose there the lips
down there the chin the forehead this is
the eye the olfactory bulb is located
immediately above the nose it's right
between your eyes within your nose other
sensory neurons you see them shown here
with these long green lines they move
from the nose up in to the first part of
the brain which is called the olfactory
bulb we'll look at that in more detail
and then from the olfactory bulb
information goes back to the rest of
cortex and I want to draw a sharp
distinction between the olfactory system
shown here and the gustatory
or the taste system shown down here they
do share some common principles is in
that they're both chemical detectors but
are otherwise quite different from each
other and in fact at the end of the what
we have three hours this morning yeah so
at the end of the three hours we'll do
an experiment in which will distinguish
between the role of smell and the role
of the gustatory or taste system in your
ability to recognize and appreciate the
flavors so this is what your head looks
like hopefully it doesn't look like that
today because there's no brain up here
this is a cross-section here's the nose
this is the external nares this is the
part of your nose right here where you
would pick your finger if you had Rhino
to lexa mania this is the olfactory
epithelium and these folds that you see
in the tissue here help to warm the air
and also help to moisturize the air the
olfactory epithelium itself is located
just here in the dorsal recess when I
say olfactory epithelium what I mean is
that part of the nose that has the
sensory neurons within it this is the
cranial cavity the brain is missing this
is the sphenoid sinus this is one of the
sinuses that can get clogged when you
get sick and you see the surface of the
tongue right down here and this is part
of the throat
we can't do most of our experiments in
humans we have to look for other models
in which we can we can we can carry out
our experiments and most of us use the
rodent or mouse olfactory system and as
a model turns out that the principles of
organization the kinds of cells that are
found there and the way the system
functions is virtually identical or
indistinguishable from what occurs in
the human so we can use the the the
rodent remember to Britt model him
another mammalian model to extrapolate
back to the human and understand what
happens so I showed you here that the
olfactory epithelium was located there
and that the brain was just up there in
the rodent the olfactory epithelium is
here again shown in green and the deal
factory bulb the first part of the brain
that receives olfactory information is
located just here on the right that
organization is shown schematically you
can see the epithelium at the top and
I'm gonna look at each of these cells in
detail with you and then at the bottom
you see the olfactory bulb where the
processes of their sensory neurons that
are shown in green and blue come in to
the olfactory bulb where they then make
contact with central components where
odor representation is finally going to
occur as an introduction the odor
molecules will come into the nose shown
up here at the top they're going to
interact with a particular a particular
detector the receptor for particular
molecules which will be expressed on the
surface of the sensory neurons the blue
and green cells and then those cells
will take that information they'll pass
it into the brain where they're going to
make a synapse or a functional contact
with other neurons that will take that
information out to higher regions of the
brain these regions where those those
contact contacts will occur are called
glomeruli and you'll see that the
glomeruli at least contribute to the
coding of olfactory information the
coding of odor information we'll find
that one glomerulus is going to detect a
particular chemical feature another
glomerulus another chemical feature and
so on and so forth as we go through all
of the clam area life so we can now look
at the olfactory epithelium in great
detail it's about the thickness of your
fingernail not the width of your
fingernail but just the
thickness of your fingernails so it's
about 500 microns it has three primary
populations of cells just three the
first population and the most important
one or the most exciting one are the
olfactory sensory neurons themselves
each of you has about a million to 5
million sensory neurons on each side of
your nose and they divide up into many
many different populations the
population that they are part of is
going to reflect the odor receptor the
molecular receptor that they express and
will look at those receptors in more
detail in a minute
these cells are called bipolar cells
that means they have two poles to them
the first pole is an apical branch it's
called a dendrite that extends to the
surface of the nose if you could get
your finger up there far enough you'd be
able to touch this part
don't try it's a bad thing to do the
second pole is called the axon and the
axon takes the information that is
initially detected by the apical portion
the dendrite and passes it into the
central nervous system where the
synapses occur now the olfactory sensory
neurons are a bit more complex as they
reach the surface of the olfactory
epithelium shown just here there's a
slight enlargement that's called a
dendritic knov and we'll see that in a
bit more detail but more importantly
there are these long processes coming
off they're called cilia now if you play
baseball you want not to play baseball
and you tried to catch the baseball just
by holding up your hand cup like that'd
be a real problem you're probably not
going to be very effective at catching
the baseball but if you put a baseball
mitt on and you have the fingers
extended and the fingers enlarged a bit
now you're gonna have a much bigger
field or a much bigger receptive area
into which you can you can try to get
that ball to go so that you can catch it
well that's what's happening up here
with these cilia we're gonna see later
on that odors come into this area and we
want to maximize the likelihood we want
to maximize the probability that when an
odorant comes in it's going to bind with
or interact or bump off of these ciliary
processes so they increase the amount of
surface area they increase the
representation of the sensory neuron at
the surface of the epithelial
and in doing so they increase the
likelihood or the probability that an
odorant will be detected by the self
once it comes into the nose yeah this is
a single cell this is a single cell this
and this anywhere from a million to five
or five or so million on each side of
unit of your nose the second population
of cells are called sussed entak euler
or supporting cells they're shown in
green here we think that they help to
detoxify the nose the nose is a nasty
nasty place right get all kinds of stuff
going up there just dirt bugs that pee
is stuffed up there when you were a
little kid and so on and so forth we
think that the sussed entak euler cells
help remove and detoxify the environment
and we also think they help remove
odorants from the environment now if you
take a quarter and you put it on your
forearm and you let it sit there for a
while when you first put it on you can
feel it quite distinctly you can
describe its shape and its weight and so
on after it has been there for a short
period of time you can no longer detect
it it's a process that's called
adaptation and all of our sensory
systems show adaptation including the
olfactory system so if we bring an
odorant into this environment and just
leave it there after a while these cells
will no longer respond then they'll bill
they'll be saturated they'll be adapted
there's no response so we need to remove
the odorants from the environment and we
think the suspect a killer cells
contribute to that process
now the third population of cells are
down here at the base they're called
basal cells or in more contemporary
terms stem cells they're perhaps among
the most interesting cells that are
found within the olfactory epithelium I
mentioned that that that the epithelium
continues to be regenerated through lut
throughout life and it's that the
vision of these basal cells or stem
cells that's responsible for that I'll
show you a little while that as one of
these cells dies the basal cell or the
stem cell will divide it'll replace it
and then allow the daughter cell or the
replace cell to differentiate
effectively and send its axon or
re-establish a connection with the
central nervous system now we've talked
about mucus so in talking about mucus at
this point it's also important to
understand where boogers come from so I
told you the nose is a toxic environment
there's lots of dirt in there it goes in
and interacts with the mucus you know of
mucus is like you've all had to blow
your nose from time to time so you know
that it's kind of sticky and gooey so
there's a little bits of dirt get in and
they clump together and when they clump
sufficiently they produce a booger so
they're really dirt so even if you take
them and line them up neatly you know on
the desk or the table next to your bed
they're still dirty so you really need
to stop doing that if you're still
persisting this behavior
so the other reason it's good to work
with the olfactory system is there are
you know these little things about it
that are kind of amusing from time to
time so coming into the nasal cavity
will be dust dirt toxins of various
sorts this sensory neuron is a neuron
it's got a very delicate membrane it's
not able to sustain its good health with
the repeated exposure to the duster and
toxin so what happens is they act on the
sensory neurons and they kill them they
die in order for olfaction to continue
then they have to be replaced and the
way they're replaced is division of the
basal cell done at the bottom now shown
in pink which gives rise to a new
daughter cell which differentiates and
sends its axon out to the brain so this
is the process of regeneration in the
olfactory system the sensory neurons die
as a result of exposure to toxins and
dirt from the environment if you work in
a coal mine for example your olfactory
epithelium is going to probably turn
over very rapidly because of the
exposure to the dust and the dirt if you
live in in you know environmentally
wonderful area where the air is
extremely clean your sensory neurons
will live a little bit longer but once
lost they're replaced by division among
this population of basal cells so this
is what it actually looks like these are
two olfactory sensory neurons there are
many different olfactory sensory neurons
that are present here they're shown in
blue this is the surface of the
epithelium that bright green line you
see at the top is where the mucus would
be the black up above it is is where the
nasal cavity is you see a cell body and
you see an apical dendrite going up to
the surface you can't see the cilia at
this level of magnification and then you
see another one next to it doing the
same thing I've mentioned a couple of
times that the sensory neurons actually
occur in many different subpopulations
so what you're looking at are two
members of just one sub pup one sub
population in this particular slide
we've stained it with a procedure in
which we're able to visualize
just small subsets of cells now if we if
we take this same image and we look at
it at a much higher level of
magnification
a much higher level of magnification
using electron microscopy what we can
see is much more detail about what it
looks like this is called scanning
electron microscopy what we do is we
take a piece of tissue we'll go into
your nose if you let us and we'll take
out a little piece of olfactory
epithelium then we'll basically hit it
with a hammer what happens when you do
that the tissue shatters into many
different pieces and what you're looking
at here is a shattered piece of tissue
the reason that's helpful for us is
it'll break across the depth of the
tissue and we can look inside at the
surface and see what it looks like this
is the equivalent of looking with a
magnifying glass at your olfactory
epithelium at a magnification of around
15,000 times it's called scanning
electron microscopy and you can see two
cells here one is the olfactory sensory
neuron just here here's the cell body
here's the apical dendrite and you see
just a little bit of the cilia up at the
top and this is the sussed intact or
tting cell that's just next to it and
what I'd like you to notice is the
surface this is the surface of the
olfactory epithelium and everything you
see there that's very white or the cilia
that I've been talking about the cilia
that increased the surface area of the
sensory neuron and increased the
probability of an odorant being detected
when it comes in and you'll see that in
in a bit more detail in the next line
okay now we're looking at an even higher
magnification this bar is about two
microns the thickness of your thumb of
you of one year of one of your
fingernails is about 500 microns so you
can judge the size accordingly this is
the dendritic nob extending out onto the
surface of the olfactory epithelium that
are coming off so they're out there
waving like this but we're gonna find
out is that some of these bumps that you
see on the surface of the cilia or where
the molecular detectors for the o-rings
are so when an odorant comes in a piece
of that odorant is going to bind at a
very small small and restricted space on
the surface of the cilia that you see
here if we look at that from a different
perspective we go back the next slide
I'm going to show you is gonna is gonna
take this and we're going to cut right
through this area so we're gonna look at
a very thin section we're gonna ask
about the density of these cilia within
a space this is what we've done here
this is called scanning electron like a
transmission electron microscopy so a
dendritic knob is here and all these
little pinwheels that you see are the
cilia remember those are the ones that
are responsible for detecting the
odorants or interacting with the
odorants when they come in you can see
how densely they're distributed at the
surface of the olfactory epithelium so
that when an odorant does come in the
likelihood of it being able to move
through this very dense field of cilia
of odor detectors without interacting
with the detector is very unlikely so we
have a dense distribution of cilia at
the surface of the olfactory epithelium
all of them designed to detect and
eventually interpret particular odors
that may come in so what happens
an odorant is going to interact with a
particular site this is the cilia the
cilia shown here then we're looking at
it at higher magnification when an
odorant we're showing it as a circle
here interacts with the molecular
receptor well look at the molecular
receptor in a minute there's going to be
a change in the electrical property of
the cell we're just one bundle of
electricity right if you press on your
finger there's an electrical event that
occurs that takes that information
carries it up your arm and into your
brain every time you see something
there's an electrical event that occurs
as you're listening to me part of your
ear is vibrating very rapidly in
response to the sound pressures that are
coming out of my mouth and as a
consequence you're able to hear well the
same thing happens in the olfactory
system it's like a spark plug you know
in a gasoline engine when there's a
spark the piston moves and the
information is carried onto the
crankshaft and the car goes well this
that's what oops sorry that's what
happens here as well the spark is the
odor binding with the receptor that
results in a change in the electrical
properties of the cell and if the change
is sufficient that information is then
carried on to the central nervous system
we can talk about that more later if you
want to but you probably won't want to
so it's okay
so one young man asked me before the
lecture started why would you want to
work in olfaction well I mean with
opportunities like this why wouldn't you
want to work in olfaction in my lab in
others we have opportunities available
for both experimenters as well as
subjects so I know this is a little
funny a faction is a billion dollar
industry billion dollar industry how
many of you have been to department
stores and walked through the perfume
section where they're selling perfumes
for hundreds of dollars a bottle
hundreds of dollars a bottle just so
that you can smell a particular way whoo
I hope everybody used a nice deodorant
soap this morning
maybe put on a little deodorant as well
those things you put in the toilet bowl
at home to make the toilet smell nice
the stuff that you spray in the house
the little things that hang from the
rear-view mirror on and on and on and on
and on a multi-billion dollar industry
and this is just one example of trying
to determine whether a particular
odorant worked I mean a deodorant worked
well also has disadvantages because it
means that we're ignoring biological
signals that help us to interact with
each other and we'll talk about that a
little bit more in a few minutes so I've
told you that that we have these
populations of sensory neurons in the
nose and that they they occur as
different subpopulations
and those subpopulations are determined
by the molecular receptor that each of
those cells expresses now if you look at
if you look again at the somatosensory
system there's a there's a nerve fiber
in the tip of my index finger and in the
tip of yours that responds specifically
specifically to high temperatures
there's another one that responds
specifically to low temperatures and
even within that there is some that are
specific for high temperatures of a very
specific range and there's some that are
specific for low temperatures within a
specific range there's another receptor
in there that responds to very high
frequency vibrations it's called a
pacinian corpuscle and there's another
one that responds to low frequency
vibrations these are called labelled
lines and what that means is a specific
detector in your somatosensory system
and your visual system or in your
auditory system is going to respond to a
very precise stimulus within your
environment your factory system does
exactly the same thing and what's
extraordinary about it is there are more
genes devoted to decoding odor
information than are devoted to any
other function in our body or any other
function in our brain by a factor of at
least 20 so in whoops I've been moving
forward and I didn't even know it so in
the mouse for example there are over a
thousand odor receptors this is called a
dendrogram we don't need to worry about
the details of this all you need to
recognize is that within the dendogram
if we look at this one little area we
see you know I don't know 25 different
odor receptors represented so the detail
that shown here not apparent here I you
know just extrapolate and recognize that
there are in the mouse over a thousand
different odor receptors that
extraordinary the visual system only has
only has only has really four red green
blue and and and kind of a night-vision
receptor the auditory system really only
has one kind of receptor it's just that
the tissue that is suspended in responds
differently somatosensory
only has about sex smell has over a
thousand it's incredible don't you think
and in fact I will mention that this was
discovered by by dr. Linda buck working
with dr. Richard axle was reported in
1991 in science and two years ago Linda
and her colleague Richard axle received
the Nobel Prize for it and Linda is only
one of seven women Nobel laureates that
have been recognized for their their
their contributions in biology yeah that
is worth applauding I have to come
closer
yes a thousand subpopulations and each
sub population will have depending upon
the animal that we're looking at the
mouse versus the human anywhere from two
thousand to ten thousand cells that are
within that population we don't know we
don't know we don't know what the
mechanism is that results in a
particular sensory neuron expressing the
odor receptor Mouse i7 for example we
don't know what regulates that process
yet
yes so if if a mouse I seven cell is
lost when it's replaced its replaced
with a cell that also expresses Mouse I
seven at least that's true during the
bulk of our life as we get older in our
80s and 90s that that process becomes
perturbed and it no longer works as well
right so basal cells we call plural
because as far as we're able to
determine any of those thousand odor
receptors that are expressed in the
mouse can be made by any any basal cell
or stem cell we don't know if they're if
they're multi potential we don't know
whether they'll generate neurons that
could replace a cortical cell for
example but in the olfactory epithelium
they replace everything yeah we don't
know it's a population of cells that
seems to be quite independent from
others we don't know what it responds to
we don't understand it yet we do know
that the gray part up at the top though
this is from the mouse but these are
also present in the human are Fishlake
receptors they respond to amino acids
the the degree of conservation that is
the degree to which the the odor
receptors expressed in mice and humans
and fish and other vertebrates are
conserved or maintained through
evolution is is is very high and these
are found exclusively I mean these are
predominant in fish with not the the tan
ones shown that all in fish yeah
so when I say Express I mean that that
that the the molecular receptor and and
think of the molecular receptor as a
pocket just gonna be a pocket into which
a molecule of a particular shape will
insert and we'll look at some of those
molecules when I say expressed I mean
that that pocket has been inserted into
the membrane of the cell so it's on the
surface and it's available to interact
with any stimuli that may come in humans
have relative to mice about 350 odor
receptors
despite that our sense of smell is much
better than you think it is you ignore
most smells you you cover them up with
deodorants or you don't comment on them
the most the most yeah or you may
comment on them you know if your little
brother was just in the bathroom and you
went in there you may have a very
specific comment for your little brother
but one of the things that we don't do
is is is we don't put our noses where
the smells our smells are usually
relatively heavy molecules maybe a foot
or so off the ground and as opposed to
dogs who are down on the ground with
their nose in the dirt following a trail
or a track we tend not to do that so if
we're if we're looking for a food source
for example in terms of species
recognition friend versus foe dogs put
their noses where the smells are and we
find it socially unacceptable to do that
yeah I can't even imagine but if we take
different species if we take dogs and
mice and humans and carry out objective
cognitive analyses of their ability to
distinguish between different odors and
their sensitivity to different odors
they're extraordinarily similar to each
other so dogs are better than us mice
are also better than us but not as much
better as you would have suspected so
I've been talking a little bit about
molecules I've been talking about odors
these are examples of odors this is what
fresh line looks like sandalwood is
gonna look like this a Gaudi mutton
smell will be like this this is urine
rose petals cheesy sweaty violet and
licorice and as you can see some of
these molecules appear relatively simple
some of them appear much more complex
but on each of these molecules there are
what the olfactory people call
determinants
there are methyl groups there are
oxygens there are hydrogen's there are
double bonds there are single bonds and
there are carbon chains and we think
that each of those kinds of determinants
will bind with a different odor receptor
and that's illustrated in the next slide
this is only to say that the odor
receptors are are have a molecular
structure and that they're inserted into
the membrane as you see here and that
there is a pocket into which an odorant
molecule or a piece of an odorant
molecule can insert so this is the fresh
lime in the citrus let's say that the
methyl group up here is equal to red and
that the oxygen is equal to green so
this is the methyl group and this is the
oxygen group now we can carry that
across and recognize that in this
particular example we have nine
different kinds of receptors we have red
squares blue-green we have half circles
and we have triangles and we can make
the model in which the Red Square is
going to bind with the Red Square
receptor the green triangle is going to
bind with the green triangle receptor
now if we carry that one step farther
and now we say all right down here with
the methyl group and the oxygen the red
square and the green triangle that's
what citrus smells like that's what
fresh lime smells like so now when we
stimulate or when we expose the organism
to this particular combination we're
going to activate again the red square
and the green diamond and that will be
then encoded as the scent of fresh lime
or citrus it's more complex than that
because there are obviously more
determinants or more features to this
molecule than just the two I've picked
out to look at but that's where the term
combinatorial code comes from so in an
odorant or what what has a particular
smell is going to have a number of
features and each of those features will
interact with a different kind of
receptor and then they'll combine and
together they'll give you this smell of
lime or coffee or that pizza that I
loved so much so what do we know so far
we know that we know that there are
sensory neurons in the nose and that
they have these ciliary processes on
them and that those cilia have molecular
receptors that respond to different
features of molecules and that as those
features are detected by those cells
that information then passes into the
central nervous system yes
Oh down here at the bottom are those
those would be other kinds of receptors
so in in the mouse they're going to be a
thousand different combinations of these
they're going to be red squares blue
squares green squares pink squares and
so on and so forth so these are just
other examples of different kinds of
odorants yes yes and we think that those
supporting or sussed entak Euler cells
may participate in that process also the
mucus that's in the nose as most of you
know is continuously flowing and it
usually goes down your throat you
swallow it and the movement of the mucus
will also help remove the odorants from
the environment okay so now let's go on
and see what happens when we move
farther into the brain so this is what
we've looked at so far the sensory
neurons the cilia at the surface the
interactions of molecules with
particular receptors now I said that
that information was going to move from
the nose from the nasal epithelium or
the olfactory epithelium to the
olfactory bulb which is the first part
of the brain that we can look at where
they're going to make connections with
other neurons that make connections with
other neurons in these spherical regions
and they are spherical as you see here
that are called glomeruli and then those
neurons in turn will take that
information and distribute it to many
other parts of the central nervous
system where it's used to regulate
feeding behavior aggressive behavior
sexual behavior and often just a sense
of well-being so let's take a look at
the olfactory bulb a little more closely
in what happens in the human I do have
some brains with me by the way that I
brought in if and afterwards when we're
done if you'd like to come and look at
them and and I'll give you a quick
little tour and I've got some gloves as
well so this is the ventral view of the
brain I'm looking up like this this is
part of the brainstem this is where the
spinal cord would come off this is
cerebellum it helps modulate movement
and what we're talking about is this
little tiny structure up here and right
there this is the olfactory bulb this is
the axons from the olfactory bulb
going back to other cortical regions
that are also responsible for processing
odor information
so our axons from our olfactory
epithelium this structure so we're back
at the epithelium once again with the
slide that I showed you before and you
see these very thin processes that are
coming off the bottom part of each of
these cells those are the axons they
move back to the olfactory bulb and you
see the left olfactory bulb and the
right olfactory bulb in the image on the
right and the green processes that you
see relative to the red are the axons
coming from all of the cells that
express the same odor receptor that
these two are expressing happens to be
an odor receptor called m71
and these axons will continue to move
across the surface of the olfactory bulb
until they find the right glomerulus
into which they want to into which they
want to go and make synapses or contact
the other cells that will take that
information to other parts of the brain
that seemed perhaps a little more
clearly here so this is from the mouse
it's called a midsagittal section we've
cut the head right down the middle so
that we can look at the olfactory bulb
we're seeing the olfactory epithelium
here and the olfactory bulb here now
rather than staining the cells that were
interested in cells of a particular sub
population that express a particular
odor receptor this happens to be odor
receptor p2 rather than looking at just
a couple of them we're looking at all of
them you can see the little dots in the
olfactory epithelium and then you see
these larger blue lines those are the
axons coming together as they're moving
from the olfactory epithelium back to
the olfactory bulb and what I hope
you'll you'll you'll recognize is that
within the nose those cells are all over
the place they're very broadly
distributed but as those axons go back
to the olfactory bulb they all terminate
in one little spot in what's called the
medial glomerulus for the p2 odor
receptor so all the cells that express
the same odor receptor that is all of
the cells that respond to the red square
or all of the cells that respond to the
green diamond and so on and so forth
or different kinds of determinants we'll
go back to just a single glomerulus
within the olfactory bulb and there are
many glomeruli now we're looking at the
surface of the olfactory bulb the noses
down here at the bottom the rest of the
brain is back here this is the left
olfactory bulb so we turned it upside
down you'd see it oriented more normally
in each of these dots that you see is a
glomerulus
there are about 1800 of them in the
mouse so they're two glomeruli two
points at which the axons expressing the
same odor receptor luckily defined
receptor converge in the olfactory bulb
so this is like a map right this is a
methyl group this is maybe a carbon
group this is an oxygen group and so on
yes
it's biology some go to - yes and there
is some variability some go to just one
many go to - it's a great question this
is the medial part of the olfactory bulb
this is the lateral part of the
olfactory bulb and each odor receptor
subpopulation goes to a medial by and
large goes to a medial glomerulus and a
lateral glomerulus and we don't know
whether they're functionally different
or not yes
it seems to be it seems to be equivalent
so the the the sensitivity the ability
of a particular molecule to elicit an
electrical event in a particular sensory
neuron seems to be equivalent across the
full population of odor receptors so
let's review
you'll factory bulb is up at the top the
olfactory epithelium we have this
enormous population of sensory neurons
all of the cells that Express the red
receptor whatever that may be
converge on to a particular glomerulus
or to glomeruli and the olfactory bulb
and from there what are called
projection neurons take that information
out to other parts of the central
nervous system where it's used to
regulate things such as appetite sexual
behavior and so on all of the green
sensory neurons there's ones that
express a different odor receptor go to
a different glomerulus and so on and so
forth for every odor receptor that's
expressed in your olfactory epithelium
so for us there would be approximately
350 different colors that would be
represented in the epithelium in the
mouse there would be approximately a
thousand different colors that are
represented in the F of ham now we yes
yes exactly
so the strength of a stimulus that is
pressing on your finger is determined by
by how great the pressure is and in turn
the strength of an odor is determined by
how many sensory neurons are activating
I'm sorry could you could you ask that
again
so most of the odorants that we know
about are blocking the odor source or
they're masking the odor source in some
way and and not we don't believe that
they're acting directly at the receptor
level we think they're acting on the on
the odorant molecules before they get
into the nose
not necessarily it's possible but it's
it's not it's not it's not a short dogs
have more sensory neurons than we do and
they do smell better but it's probably
because they have more molecular
receptors and not just more sensory
neurons
yes that's a great question so if what
happens when when a green odorant
activates a red receptor cell it doesn't
happen very often but when it does
happen you can misinterpret the smell
and think it's something else the
analogy would be you know if I come
along and punch you in the eye I won't
do that but if I did you would see light
there would be a light flash that would
happen it's not because your retina or
the receptor cells in your eye were
properly stimulated it's because of the
physical deformation that occurs so the
stimulus is inappropriate but there's
still a sensory like event that occurs
we can have similar effects in the
olfactory system
boy what come work in my lab no we don't
understand that it's it's it's it's it's
an intense area of study right now it's
important not only for the olfactory
system but it's important for people
that have had strokes traumatic brain
injury from car accidents spinal cord
injury and so on and so forth so there
are a lot of labs that are interested in
that very problem and looking at it not
just in the olfactory system but
elsewhere in the brain as well
and that's a hard question um you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna skirt it a little
bit by giving you a couple of examples
um we know that if your mother ate a lot
of garlic when she was carrying you when
she was pregnant with you
you're gonna like garlic now your
postnatal experience as you're growing
up you're probably mother probably still
likes garlic and there's gonna be a lot
of it in the cooking but we know that
that that in utero experience when
you're floating around in the amniotic
fluid of the womb that there are are
smells and tastes that can pass the
barriers that are found and they will
influence your preferences so we can
take a rat and we can inject the odor of
peppermint into its amniotic fluid after
the rat is born we cross foster it we
put it with another mother that has
never seen doesn't know anything about
peppermint she'll raise up that rat
litter and they'll be just fine and
normal and then later six months old a
year old we take those rats or those
mice and we put them in a situation in
which who we say would you rather be
around peppermint or would you rather be
around normal cage smells or spearmint
or some other odor
beside normal case smells are awful so
you know pizza smells they'll go with
the peppermint they'll go with the
peppermint every time
they'll also preferentially mate with
with another female that are with a
female that's scented with peppermint as
well so we know these associations come
on very early in the embryo beyond that
I think it's you know it's a positive
experience if you go out with your
friends you have a great time and you
know it's the first time you've had a
combination pizza but everybody's having
a good time and you're laughing it's
reinforcing you know you you you you
like that experience and you associate
that with the food you can contrast that
with going out and and you know maybe a
lot of you have not yet gone out and and
had a pizza and gotten really sick
afterwards
now it's an aversive relationship and
now when you smell that combination
pizza
it's disgusting you don't want to go
near it my sister fixed eggs for me when
I was little and I got very sick for who
what reason I cannot stand the smell of
eggs I won't I don't want to be anywhere
around them and it's because I got sick
just once called one trial learning it's
a survival mechanism
Yeah right so there's a there's a
there's a famous author from the turn of
the century of french philosopher and
author Marcel Proust who wrote a book a
huge volume called remembrance of things
past and what he talks about is the the
the the power of a particular sensory
experience an odor in this case to
elicit a flood of memories so as an
adult he was having a cookie with some
tea in it and it elicited in him this
incredible warmth and remembrance of the
events that had taken place when he was
a child and he was having tea and a
cookie with his mother hadn't thought of
it in decades years and years and years
but suddenly that smell stimulated that
memory and it just came flooding back
olfaction seems to be particularly
strong in that way you can you can go to
your grandparents house or your home
where you haven't been in years years
and years and years and you walk in and
you know you're home you know you're
home immediately from the smell
sure um so I pointed out already that
the olfactory the sensory neurons in the
nose are very delicate and can you think
of anything nastier well I can think of
other nasty Oh things but smoke is
certainly among the nasty things to put
in your nose and if you keep killing
these cells again and again and again
unnecessarily
you're gonna have a decrease in your
sense of smell we know that people that
have been heavy smokers and then stopped
that within a period of time that we
think is is consistent or appropriate
for reconstitution of the olfactory
epithelium with sensory neurons their
sense of smell will return or it will
improve dramatically at the very least
so smoking is a toxin you know you take
a drag on a cigarette you blow it out
through your nose you're gonna be
exposing those sensory neurons you're
going to be killing them and you're
going to be killing them so fast that
sense of smell will decline
yeah
yeah but your parents might not like it
if we gave you that virus and got your
really sick but in fact we do
experiments like that we take a drug
called lithium chloride and we'll expose
an animal to a smell and then we inject
them with lithium so the question was
could we do an experiment in which we
expose someone a kid to the smell of
smoke and then give them a virus that's
going to make them really sick and then
make them be may make the smoke aversive
to them to keep them from smoking in the
future and in fact we do experiments
like that on a regular basis with rats
not with smoke but with with other
things we'll expose them to an odorant
then we inject them with a drug called
lithium chloride which is the equivalent
of the worst stomachache you've ever had
and then we ask them later on now are
you willing to be exposed to this
particular odor that you previously
liked and they don't want to have
anything to do with it it's like with me
in the egg so you we can in fact do that
three hours right
it's called state-dependent learning and
and what happens is that is that there's
evidence that that individuals do better
when the environment when the when the
testing environment the classroom is the
same as the environment in which they're
studying and in fact on the front page
of the New York Times several weeks ago
there was an article about that very
very phenomenon in which in which
individuals that studied around the
smell of roses and then were exposed to
rose the scent of roses while they were
sleeping
showed evidence of having a better
memory the next day for for the material
that they had studied math or literature
whatever it might have been but how that
works is not well understood
God how awful what happens if there are
people that have never smelled pizza
before can you imagine anything terrible
so that happens all the time
you know kids that grow up in different
cultures
my background is Swedish among the
sweets during holiday seasons there's a
there's a fish that served that's called
lutefisk that is disgusting for most
people but I grew up with it so I happen
to think it's fabulous and that happens
that happens a lot there's certainly
people my wife doesn't like pizza
I mean how awful is this my favorite
food in the world and my wife doesn't
like it so I don't get to have it as
often as I like but you're absolutely
right you know there are people that can
like and dislike based upon their early
experience let me go quickly through a
couple of slides because at the end I'd
still like to do this experiment which
means jelly beans which is a good thing
and I also have these human brains up
here for you all to come down and look
at if you'd like to yeah yeah I think so
yeah
I hope so I'll tell you a little bit
more about the brains before we before
we get there so we can make some we can
make some predictions about way of the
way in which odor information is going
to be represented that the cells that
detect green odorants will go to the
green glomerulus and the cells that
detect red odorants will go to the red
glomerulus and we can carry that on with
the model that we established earlier
remember the methyl group is going to be
red and the oxygen is going to be green
so it's going to activate a very
specific subset of receptors and because
all of the receptors that Express the
same molecular odor receptor go to the
same glomerulus in the olfactory bulb if
we expose a rat or a mouse to this
particular molecule and we know that
this is the code we can now predict with
certainty that this glomerulus and this
glomerulus or these two regions of the
olfactory bulb will be the ones that
will show functional activity following
X following exposure to this particular
odorant so you know can we test that and
we find out if that's really true we can
do that in mice so this is a little hard
to look at but we're looking down at the
surface of the olfactory bulb these
black lines are the blood supply this is
a live animal and when functional
activity occurs it's going to appear as
this very black area through image
processing we can determine that the
blackest areas are indicated here in red
and we can then carry that image
processing further and identify the
fiscal Maryalice this glomerulus and
this glomerulus or the three glomeruli
in this particular animal that responded
to the odorant that the animal was
presented with so it wasn't it wasn't
lime it was it was an odorant called
amyl acetate that smells like bananas
but these were the three glomeruli that
were active so the model that we had in
which a particular subset of sensory
neurons in the nose will be active with
exposure to a particular orand will then
result in the activation or functional
activity in a particular subset of
glomeruli in the olfactory bulb seems to
hold true these other glomeruli are
inactive yes
so so there are lots of ways to do it we
can we can look at changes in the levels
of ions calcium sodium potassium the
other thing that happens is when your
brain is active the cells that are there
will swell and shrink a little bit and
when they swell and shrink the degree to
which a light reflects off the surface
of the brain changes and that's what
this is this is a change in reflectance
that we have shown in the past and
others have shown in the past is
associated with functional activity you
can also use a something like functional
MRI that you may have heard it in the
past MRI is usually used in a diagnostic
way but you can also look at functional
activity in human brain I'm using MRI as
well oh they're just to identify
landmarks so that as you go from image
to image to image and you're processing
it through the computer you can even
coordinate where things are so if you
continue with this model doing that kind
of thing
you know the c3 through the c7 down here
what those are specifically is not
important but wrecking
determinants or different components of
odorant odorant molecules and what we're
showing you here is that different
odorants will activate different regions
of the olfactory bulb so there's a map
on the olfactory bulb different kinds of
odorants will activate different regions
subsets of sensory neurons respond to
very specific components or pieces parts
of molecules they put those together and
then they all project into the olfactory
bulb where they activate subpopulations
of glomeruli and that in turn is
converted into a map on the surface of
the olfactory bulb and with experience
and by looking at lots of different
odorants we can look at a map like this
and we can tell you what the odorant was
so in the same way that we can look at a
map of your finger in the surface of
your brain which we do very effectively
we can now look at the surface of the
olfactory bulb as well and tell you what
kind of odor or at least what class of
odorant you may have been exposed to as
or that results in that particular
pattern of activity no I'm almost done I
promise another hour and a half will be
there I've mentioned to you that
odorants effect behavior I told you that
in utero that you've had you had odor
experiences that influence preferences
and things you liked after you were born
in utero you're exposed to the amniotic
fluid that you're floating in in the
womb and when your firstborn
your initial suckling your initial
attachment to your mother's nipple to
initiate suckling behavior was
determined vinyl factory queue if we
take the breast pads from two mothers
that gave birth the same same time same
day same day of the birth and we take
two take the two infants from mother a
and mother B and expose them to the
breast paths from mother a and mother B
and ask which one there they oriented to
or which one they prefer baby a from
mother a Orient's preferentially to to
breast pad a and baby B Orient's
preferentially to breast pat B from the
wall if we change the amniotic fluid it
changed the odors that are there not in
humans but in animals
now they'll no longer suckle or initiate
suckling on a normal breast that is one
that is unscented they'll only go for
the scented breast so olfaction less so
among humans now because the mothers you
know can obviously control the infant
and their behavior a bit more precisely
but among other species dogs rats cats
mice so on and so forth mammalian
species suckling is a critical
determinant for survival you don't smell
you don't eat and you die so at the very
least an important determinant among
rodent populations mice and rats
olfaction is a critical determined
determinant in mate selection thank you
you smell right I'll mate with you if
you don't smell right I won't make with
you now I know what you're all thinking
I'm a human you know I'm above that I'm
more sophisticated than that but in fact
when we look at isolated breeding
populations of humans places like
Pitcairn Island for example where the
selection
breeding opportunities or selection of
mating opportunities marriages I guess
it's more limited which you can
recognize is that there is an order
specificity that occurs there as well we
have a number of markers that we can use
to demonstrate that so odor selection is
a determinant for preference and some of
you that are older perhaps you've you
know you've been dating already and you
can recognize that you know I don't want
to be around that guy versus how you
know that's okay so you know it
influences your daily behavior it
influences your food preference I need I
need yeah so there while they're passing
out jelly beans
do you know take several jelly beans
from the bag do not eat them yet don't
put them in your ears and don't put them
up your nose just hold on to them as
soon as everybody has and it has you
know three or four or five six jelly
beans then I'll describe the experiment
to you
I haven't talked about that no parallel
system called the accessory olfactory
system that may or may not be present in
humans it's not clear are there are
there other questions I can I can do
right now while the jelly beans are
being passed out yes
yeah yeah so so it is used in pest
control and I think even more
importantly some of you may you guys
still hear me yeah okay so some of you
may have heard John Carlson's talk last
week and I think the work that John is
doing on on on looking at mechanisms of
olfaction in mosquitoes that are vectors
for malaria is perhaps the best example
and one of the most profound examples of
how people are interested in
understanding how olfaction works in
order to control what is otherwise a
devastating disease it's also true that
that if if we could control the the
number of crops the grains of food that
is destroyed by pests in the United
States if we could control that thrall
faction hunger would be obliterated it
would be gone yeah
so we've just started a new program
project with Linda buck and when they
got the the Nobel Prize to ask that very
question we don't know why olfaction in
humans as they get older goes into
decline well I'm sorry
so the question was this is does
something happen to the stem cell
population in the aged that results in
in decline in olfactory function and can
we understand how stem cells work by
looking at that and and the answer to
the question is we think so and yes
we've just started that project with
Linda Bach to take a look at that very
question what happens what are the what
are the underlying mechanisms that are
responsible for the decline in olfaction
that occurs in the agent and one very
real possibility is that the the
reproduction of new cells by the stem
cell population decreases so how fast is
that neural epithelium olfactory
epithelium regenerate and it takes about
if you destroy the entire thing which we
can do chemically it takes about six
weeks for the entire epithelium to be
reconstituted and connect with the
olfactory bulb very badly I mean many of
you have found a diminished sense of
smell after a bad viral infection of
your olfactory system and it's it's slow
to recover
if there's traumatic injury you can
sometimes have the formation of a scar
and then the organization of the system
is destroyed the distribution within the
epithelium stays the same but with a
scar it sometimes means that their
ability to innervate centrally the
olfactory bulb is is decreased she was
first
again
these oh the clot is wet on top of them
otherwise normally the brain in the
skull is suspended in a large vat of
fluid that's called cerebral spinal
fluid so the brain is actually floating
all the time
I mean that certainly contributes so
there's a lot of mucus production and
the sinuses get clogged and then pumping
out junk but our experiment that I'm
about to do will bear on that
they could use you for drug detection
it's just a question it's just a
question of training it takes 2 or 3
years to train a dog to detect drugs or
to detect plant products if you've seen
them at the International Arrivals that
JFK at a JFK or Dulles for example you
see the beagles running around beagles
are good because they're small they're
amicable everybody likes beagles as
opposed to Doberman Pinschers which
produce a different reaction so it's
just you know it's just a convenient
animal but it takes about 2 to 3 years
to train one to detect a particular
substance and and to behave in the
appropriate way and even then that
training has to be continually
reinforced
sure so so there there are lots of
odorants that have clinical consequences
associated with them and as you pointed
out some odorants are irritants
you know if you smell them it burns your
nose that doesn't have really anything
to do with the sense of smell it has to
do with other sensory systems in the
nose like the trigeminal for example
that respond to somatosensory
information and not not the olfactory
system per se okay all right all right
so let me let me let me first tell you
what you're gonna do and then we'll walk
through and actually do it all right so
don't do anything yet what I'm gonna
have you do well all right when you have
that combination pizza that you really
love or that I really love how many
think that it's your mouth that's
telling you what you're tasting partly
okay so partly at least
okay so let's test that what you're
gonna do don't do it yet is your gonna
picture those very tightly don't do it
yet picture dough is very tightly so
that no air is moving through so you
can't breathe through your nose why your
nose is pitched why your nose this pinch
you're gonna put the jelly beans in your
mouth keeping your nose pinched while
you do it
put the jelly beans in you're gonna chew
and just chew for a few seconds and I'll
tell you when to let your nose go okay
so pinch the noses Alleman once ya go
for the full experience the combination
all right pinch that the nose has got to
be pitched before the jelly beans go in
all right those pinch jelly beans in
choo-choo-choo some texture some
sweetness that's coming off of the
tongue okay let go your noses
works every time
so what happens is this this is your
mouth this is your tongue your tongue
responds to sweet sour salty and bitter
and that's yet doesn't give you flavor
doesn't give you that cherry flavor
blueberry flavor Island punch I think
was the other one that I had in there
what happens is when the nasal cavity is
paitent when you don't have a cold
or when your nose is open normally air
from your mouth goes this way it's
called the retro nasal pathway it goes
from your mouth very rapidly up into
your olfactory epithelium stimulates the
olfactory sensory neurons and you have
the experience of cherry combination
pizzas if you're you know if you're a
wine drinker though you see the wine
people smelling all the time it's to
activate these areas up here when we
block the nose we blocked the flow of
air up there and as a consequence you
block perception if you're old enough
when you were little maybe your mother
pinched your nose while you had to take
some medicine that didn't taste good
pitch to nose so you couldn't taste it
so that's what you've experienced today
and thanks very much